hey everyone welcome back to the world
podcast i'm james marshall and man we're
flying through season two
lots of great guests and another one of
the greats on here for you today
but before we get into it i need to make
a mention of our sponsors firstly
straight face razors they've come on
board
with a mission to solve the problem of
ever having to shave with a blunt razor
so what they can do is deliver a sharp
five blade razor
to your door with 50 off discount
mind-blowing stuff absolutely
mind-blowing so to order head to
wallet.com click the straight face logo
down the bottom and the discount will be
applied
all ready to go also todd's racing on
board and i love this
champion harness trainer regan todd he
just wanted to sponsor the podcast
basically because he's a lad so go do
him a favor and follow todd's racing on
facebook
and twitter it'll be much appreciated by
everyone
also if you want some great coffee get
yourself some water coffee beans made by
pomeroys
lots of great feedback on how good these
coffee beans are
so go get amongst it anyway let's get to
it roll the intro please
[Music]
now today we have one of the greats on
the show he started off as a wellington
lion sensation before becoming a
highlander legend
leading them to their first ever super
rugby title he's played for the mighty
stags down in southland and of course he
reached the ultimate heights of becoming
an all black
for the last three years he was over in
the uk playing for the wasp
which i'm really looking forward to
hearing all about and above all like all
my guests ah
this man is an absolute lad one of the
greats it is
lima sopowanga welcome mate thanks for
coming on hey thanks for awesome to be
here
love watching your podcast so the sort
of you know last couple of months
especially in lockdown um
said you've had some pretty crack up
guests
and uh some pretty cool stories you know
um along the way and
it's uh it's cool to be on here today
and you know hopefully uh somebody else
could get something from it too
yeah another crack up guy today and cool
stories to come looking forward to
but how is isolation obviously um you've
been there for how many days now
bro honestly i couldn't tell you how
many days i've been here
we got three kids three and under and um
yeah we're in auckland at the moment at
the stamford plaza but to be
fair the the accommodation and the food
here is
unbelievable um so that's a bonus
but yeah i i think it might be sort of
day five or day six and
yeah it's just all morphing into one and
we're just trying to get to
uh not this wednesday but next wednesday
and and then yeah
we should be uh we should be good and
hopefully i'm still alive by then
how are you spending your day three
girls under under three did you say
yeah three girls three and under um
so we usually we usually wake up right
the girls are still but jet lagged
yeah so depending on what sort of you
know sometimes they're going to be it at
like
five o'clock and sometimes they're going
to be at it
11 o'clock at night it's just we just
it's literally just the luck of the draw
bro and then yeah just during the days
we just
try and just have a bit of fun but a
drawing um
you know a few movies a few obstacle
courses
uh we try to get out for some walks um
twice a day you sort of get
um at this one it's you're allowed out
twice a day
for half an hour i'm pretty sure you get
more freaking free time
in prison but um
but but that's all we got and that you
know we we'll we'll take that man we'll
take that and then uh
we also sometimes they're sort of having
sort of maybe two baths a day you know
just to kind of
take up time it's the time to yeah you
know wake up
have a bath that's an hour you know just
before you go to bed oh that's another
hour you know so
stuff like that bro that's pretty much
what's keeping us going
how long have been since you've been
away from new zealand well it's been
three years since i've been home
you haven't come back once true no i
haven't come back once so
i didn't plan to have it that way but
obviously with coven and
sort of everything that's happened
that's just how it's worked out but
uh back home now and just sort of
counting the days until we can get out
because
yeah it was a little bit anti-climatic
sort of coming into
like landing in auckland and being like
yes i'm home but it's just like no
get over there get in your freaking box
and come out in 14 days you know what i
mean but crazy yeah
it's um yeah it's cool to be here and
sort of look out the window and
and see the sun shining in the middle of
winter because it's a bit different in
the uk and went to you know
did you and the family enjoyed over
there though yeah we did enjoy it
um obviously it's it's a little bit
tough moving away to begin with and i
think
the sort of first 18 months of just
trying to find our feed and
find a community and and sort of build
relationships was um
was pretty tough but you know when it
came to leave
uh the uk we were pretty sad to leave
we'd met some unbelievable people
and you know some real friends for life
and i think that's
probably the beauty of of rugby you know
we we get to go on this journey and and
the special thing about it is the people
you meet and the relationships you build
and
we built some pretty amazing ones um
not only in the rugby circle but out of
the rugby circle and
pretty sad to to let those let those go
but
also know that those those relationships
will be around for our lifetime so
yeah we wouldn't have those if we did if
we didn't leave
uh new zealand you know 100 and you had
a good kiwi crew over there it was with
you too didn't you
yeah we had an awesome kiwi crew um we
always used to um
give brad stick and just say he was he
was now english and he wasn't a kiwi
anymore
so he used to used to get upset about
that you know be like ah you need to go
over there
english boys you're not you're not kiwi
anymore man so we had him
um we had uh jimmy corpus
um jeff jeff ended up coming jeff to
among ellen
malachi was there and then there was
obviously a few um
a few safers as well which was pretty
cool um
john dion if we had um sort of willie
leroux there
one point ashley johnson um
nizam car and we sort of had nathan
hughes as well so that was
he was there too he'd been in england
for like six
to seven years and yeah it was a pretty
cool um
international contingent there so it was
it was awesome and how did you find the
rugby
obviously it's a massive shift i know as
a 10 going from
super rugby to the english premiership
how did you find it
yeah i think i think my transition there
was probably a little bit
a little bit hard to be fair i probably
went over there a little bit naive
um and thinking that rugby was just all
the same
everywhere but the the premiership is
definitely um
definitely something pretty pretty
hardcore to be fair
um and it's just a totally different
style of rugby and a totally different
way of playing the game and
it's very nutritional and it's very sort
of like set piece orientated and
and i didn't realize how like bad the
winters were going to be yeah so
probably didn't really suit my game
um when i went over there i was probably
kind of like i said a little bit naive
to the fact that
the game would be played totally
different to how i'd been used to
and um yeah it really took me a lot of
time to adjust and i don't even think i
fully adjusted and fully like
sort of was able to reach the heights
that i believed i could get to but
you know that's just the way it is
sometimes and
i've definitely learned a lot from that
experience
um on the field and hopefully i can take
that forward to
to france so when you when you went over
there did you try and get the guys to
start playing the way that you wanted
them to or did you just sit back and
sort of play the style that they wanted
to play
i tried to to fit in as quickly as i
could but it was really hard you know i
um they had obviously had cipriani there
the year before
yeah and then you know i was kind of
like a marquee signing to come in and
sort of um you know replace him and
you know sort of steady the ship and and
take us to
you know better heights and whatever but
yeah i just didn't i just didn't
eventuate like that especially my first
season i just found it really
sort of difficult because i didn't know
the guys and the guys didn't know me
and sort of the way i didn't realize how
i didn't realize how much
being around guys continuously for
like a certain amount of years really
helped your game like i
i'd played with aaron smith for eight
years i played for
ben smith for eight years and so by the
time i had left
you know i i had had those guys around
me all the time and to be fair i was
just like oh
like if i look back now i was probably
like man those guys took so much
pressure off my shoulders and
you know i benefited from from having
those guys around and my game ended up
elevating
um because of those guys whereas where
now it's a wasp i wasn't
i was kind of like that guy and i think
that
i didn't really adjust to that that well
sure yeah that's interesting makes sense
100 i get that because like you say
those combinations that you grow and
everything starts becoming a little bit
more instinctive rather than
planned and talked about and all that
sort of stuff so to have to go into
the wash side without knowing anyone
having those connections with anyone
with the pressure of you as being the
big marquee guy
it makes it real tough yeah it was man
and then sort of the
style of rugby we were playing it wasn't
really a style that
um i was used to and it was just
different everything was just different
and
i i couldn't i think it was a little bit
down to me as well because i
i wanted everything to be so much like
home whereas
if i maybe just embraced the english way
of playing football i think my
transition would have been
uh so much easier but because i was
i'd only known sort of one thing for for
so long
yeah when i came into a new setup i was
like what is this like this isn't like b
you know like i was like what is going
on here like
what we're attacking off the scrub yeah
yeah i was just like oh just just little
things
but it wasn't it wasn't like their phone
it wasn't my fault i just think that
um yeah maybe i could have been a bit
more open-minded
to change and i think that would have
made things speed up a little bit better
and i would have gotten to
sort of get on top of the ball a lot
quicker yeah and obviously you were
playing under the roof
at um foresight bar to going over to the
english
winter and you like you say the
conditions are completely different
oh bro honestly i didn't by looking back
now
that a lot of people talk about like
seasonal depression
i was just like what is that like
there's no such thing and i look back
now i was like yeah
there's such a thing as seasonal
depression like i'd be going to work at
like 7
30 and it's pitch black and then by the
time i go like
nine or ten o'clock it's still like gray
and
sort of like half light but more so dark
and then
you jump in the car to get home it's
like four o'clock or 3 30 and it's like
pitch black again and you're just like
this is this is just you know like this
is just out the gate
like i knew something was bad in winter
when i rang home one
uh once and my mom looked at me and she
was just like what's wrong with you i
was like what she's like
you look sick and they're just like and
i was like i didn't realize and i looked
and i was like holy i've like
lost my whole color i hadn't seen the
sun and mom's saying
you look sick yeah i was like
but yeah those those winters um
yeah there's something else eh yeah oh
tough times
anyway like all successful careers we've
got a lot to get through on this one so
um like all stories we need to start at
the start
take us back to the start for you i
guess the staff
me you know like um like you said in the
intro uh wellington boy
uh born and bred i've got i've got five
brothers and sisters three brothers and
two sisters so
yeah grow up and grow up out in lower
heart um
played all my junior rugby at the mighty
patoni
so so so played out there um
had grew up sort of with the likes of um
you know like mike king and brad shields
and yeah um
jordan kahu and and tj and and arty and
all them so kind of just you know we
would cross paths
um on saturday sort of playing those
guys so that was that was pretty cool
and then um lived out in the hut most of
my life well
actually all of my life um out on
analyst town and then
i went to hotbelly high in my first
high school year and so i was out there
with
sort of all my friends who had grown up
with around the neighborhood and then
in my year 10 year or four for me
um it was probably about a week to go
before school started and i was like oh
we better go get my my uniform
to um get ready to go to high and
my mom sat me down and she was like oh
no you're not going there anymore
i was like what she's like now you're
going to
all boys school in wellington college
and i was just like i was just sat there
just like gobsmacked like
and i was like you know like spewing it
like why the hell would i go
there like i don't know anybody like i
had never heard of wellington college
before
my mom was like nah you're going there
and that's that and i was just like no
but all my friends
you know how you are when you're like 13
40 years old you just think
and i was at a co-ed school too so you
know i was kind of like walking around
thinking i was like
the guy you know like yeah this is my
school you know trying to be like what's
the cool guy you know
you would have been yeah yeah
so it was me and my mate jordan kahu and
like we were just like biggest thieves
so
you know we were we were that guy you
know the dex waxing you're here the
straightener out that kind of thing you
know
and so i was just like nah nah i'm not
going i'm not going and then
she's like okay well just give it to the
first term and if you
if you don't like it you can return and
i liked it so much that i ended up
going back for second year seven you
know
yeah i loved it that much man i went
back for second year seventh but
that's how it kind of all began for me
you you were always a gun
um player back at college though as well
okay because i remember watching your
game
you might have been eighth form or ninth
form by then
it was a quad tournament against uh
nelson college and you were
you were running a muck out there one
day yeah
yeah i was all right i was all right so
yeah i was
yeah i ended up um being pretty decent
at
high school um which was
sort of lucky for me i guess um and that
probably helped a lot
yeah uh going forward but yeah those
tournaments were were real cool i think
we played sort of like mitch scott and
like and
and j lo and that i think that yeah we
played at uh
nelson college i remember that yeah it
was funny because i actually i don't
know if you know them but do you know
jeff and karen reckley yeah yeah yeah i
do know jeffree
yeah yeah yeah so we ended up getting
bulleted by them
me and one of one of the boys and funny
enough
um they ended up having joe wheeler come
over
you for dinner joe rocks up you know
with his freaking jandals on and he's
like oh gay boys you know
you know we're just like two quiet kids
you know like yeah
from from from the city we're like frank
jesus big white guy like
before this big ugly grin on his face
you know like couldn't shut him up
we were just like oh yes yeah yeah you
know like not giving him much because so
sure
yeah but yeah no that's that's one of my
memories from that tournament
that's crack up and so you made new
zealand schools after that year
oh it's funny because in my seventh form
yeah i'll be one of the
like i've never been so heartbroken in
my life before so i was just like
yeah but i was young so i was just like
nah i can't i can't i can't leave
like this like i was like no i'm going
back to school yeah
so i missed out on my seventh for me and
then my age for me i actually ended up
making new zealand secondary schools
that was purely for rugby was it
wasn't for your academics nah i was
actually not too bad at school like i
didn't
need to go back academically but i i
wanted to go back
for sport and it was we actually had
sort of like five or six guys who went
back
yeah and they kind of like put us in our
like our own classroom and we had like
um like special periods where we didn't
actually start school till like 11 30.
and and things like that yeah so it was
actually wild man like the teachers
didn't even
like treat us like students they almost
treated us like we were
sort of like first year uni kind of
thing you know like semi-pro
yeah yeah it was actually like you know
sort of the era just before you know
like
before all that kind of like sky tv
stuff came in and schools
like started having like proper
curriculum yeah whereas we were kind of
like
they were like oh what do we do with all
these guys who are coming back and they
kind of stuck us all together and we
would like
only have like two classes a day and
like some of our classes were like go to
the gym or
yeah like some of them were like oh
you're supposed to be running fitness
but we were down at mcdonald's kind of
like
just hanging out and stuff like that and
like just wagging school and things like
that and just
making sure we were there for for rugby
and footy but it was one of the best
years of my life
going back how good is that and then
obviously you were in
to the wellington lions set up pretty
young i remember you playing for them it
must have been about 19.
yes i left for 2009 and 2010 was the
year that
jamie joe was coaching yeah so i would
have been
yeah i would have just been 18 that year
um
yeah and he and we were sort of all in
the academy together
and yeah i remember just going to sort
of
those dog sessions at like six o'clock
in the morning you know
those sessions so i was going there at
six and then i was
i was going to my job that i had and i
was like washing cars
because this is when i i i'd never had
like sort of money grow
at school like had no job i was just too
busy playing sport yeah
so i was like oh what do i want to do
like go to uni or make some money so
okay i'll try and make some money so i
was getting like a you know you get your
first pu contract and it's like
i think mine was like 12 grand for the
year
and i was just like yeah i was like oh
man i'm rich you know like so i'd have
to go
to training from six to like 7 38 and
then i went and watched cars
yeah um down at uh mitsubishi just sort
of by the base in there you know when
you come around and do that
sort of like the on the corner so i used
to work there by washing the cars who
had
and the cars had come in for like
services and one of their things they
got a complimentary wash
yeah i remember just sort of like
washing all the cars and things like
that and
you know i'd find like um underneath
their seats like two dollars and stuff
and i had
no money at the time bro i had no food
so i'd like to take that two dollars and
go put it in the machine and get some
chips and
and a cookie so i could have some food
but i was [ __ ]
so poor i just remember just washing
cars saying
[ __ ] man i've made it i've made it you
know and i get my pay at the end of
every month and be like
ah what a lie i think it was like 400
bucks
how much change oh man i'll tell you
what there was a lot of loose change
that i'd found
and [ __ ] gone and you know put yes
there's a dollar coke
and there's like a cookie time man i was
i was scrounging around a lot back in
those days but
i did that yeah i did that for
ages um sort of until we
just before they were going to name that
first lion squad and
then yeah i ended up getting being
picked in it
um funnily enough i didn't think i had a
had a shot but
i had some pretty solid like one-off
games where i think
jamie joe actually came and watched
because he i played for obu and he
played for ovu so i think he came a lot
to those games to sort of
more so watch his mates or you know
catch up and drink on the bank or
whatever
and i just happened to be playing and
some i think some of the games he
watched i actually went pretty decent so
i think that's actually how i ended up
getting picked to be fair
sharon how was it going into that set up
as a young 18 year old
that's been pretty intimidating as a ten
but from the outside you always look
like a real confident guy like someone
who
was happy to be running the cutter and
didn't matter who was who was around you
did you always feel like that yeah i
always felt um
i always felt confident but i never felt
like too overruled by it all but i was
always like
underneath it all i was like shaking or
yeah i was like super super excited
and back then some of the guys they were
still playing item because i think it
was kind of just
it was just phasing out of that period
where all blacks weren't playing itn
but we we still had a few like we had
the mere tialata
um you know like kazakh pity weepy play
um
ronnie soyallo um and like nanu and that
was
crystal sort of around the place yeah so
it was kind of cool to just
sort of rub shoulders with those guys
and i was i was just like a sponge and
just
so excited to be around them and just
so nervous but i also sort of had this
like
fear of of being like [ __ ] you know or
like them being like [ __ ] this like [ __ ]
like what a waste of
what a waste of money bringing this guy
in so i always was just trying my best
out there like
to not to not be scared or to not sort
of mess up
so i think that kind of worked in my
favor a little bit
and yeah it was just an exciting time i
reckon and you got the starting spot
before the end of the season a and
i think you guys made the final that
year yeah i ended up
so i was on the bench for like four
games because
tony philly was um was playing and he
was he was actually someone who
who took me under his wing and um who
guided
guided me a lot and really helped me and
that's something i'll never ever forget
as a young guy was someone who was
sort of older just really giving someone
young
the time of day and that's something
that's really stuck with me throughout
my career
as well just to just to always remember
that and
and um yeah he he ended up helping me a
lot i
i was on the bench for like four games
and then i came on against my note2
and then um i think ticks actually
um got an intercept with like three
minutes to go and you've ran the length
of the field and
um scored and we lost but i just
remember being out there just thinking
[ __ ] this is
this is this is next level like this is
too much for me
like i remember thinking oh man this is
not um
club rugby anymore like this is just a
level that i've never
been exposed to and i'll say holy [ __ ] i
don't know if i'm
if i'm made for this but you know as as
i got more confident
and and things um i started to
sort of believe in myself a bit more i
started to um really enjoy myself in
that environment but
it was pretty daunting going in there
initially and
and just being around all those old guys
and
wendell was like riding me hard as well
like he was so
he was actually so mean to me as a
trainer i remember like some days yeah
i mean so i remember we were we were
doing like um like 15 on 15 and
obviously i wasn't like
the guys who weren't going to play um
kind of thing yeah like the 923
and i remember the ball being kicked
down and i remember chasing it and jose
jose picked the ball up jose gear yeah
he picked the ball up and he probably
had about 30 meters between me and him
and um he so he picks it up and he's
running dead straight at me like
full full tip and so i like
yeah so i'm like oh man i'm just gonna
have to put my head down and like
i might brace and just get ready to get
[ __ ] steamrolled
and so i'm just like getting ready and
at the last like two meters yeah
he just steps and goes around me like
he's like running three straight and
then
the last two meters like i fall on plant
and i'm like yeah i'm gonna
bang it like put my body on the line and
try to get in front of them yeah
and he just like goes yeah and goes
around me and then wendell just like
lamer what are you doing
what is that and i was just like i just
remember turning around just
thinking oh my gosh that is not what i
want to see
or what i want to hear like the train is
just belting me on the side i'm like
get back and chase him i'm like oh the
cunt's gone 40 and scored the try
what am i supposed to do he's like
world-class winger
18 years old like 80 kilo dripping where
you reckon so i just try to brace myself
and i think i must have closed my eyes
because
he ended up going around me
i was like oh man you obviously
impressed jamie joe enough to
play a lot of games towards the back end
of that season eh
yeah i must have um it's funny you
try to think back to it now but when
you're so young i think you're just so
oblivious to it all right so i was kind
of just like oh yeah whatever this is
just
normal but now that i think about it i'm
just like oh [ __ ] i can't even really
remember because
when i was in that moment i was just you
know like it was
just it was like you're in a dream you
know like you're in a trance you're just
like man this is
wicked like i'm pretty weak boobs pass
me the ball i know when who's at 12 you
know like jose gear's on one wing and
yeah
you know corey jane comes in every now
and then because he's
with all blacks or whatever and it was
just it was just crazy
you know like you're just kind of just
like living the stream and
you don't really stop to think like
how cool it actually is and so now when
i get after that i'm just like oh [ __ ]
and i wish i stopped and smelt the roses
a little bit on the way up you know
100 and then jamie joe obviously got you
down to
the highland as he took took you down
with him was that a hard decision for
you did you have other options
i i imagine you were probably wanting to
be a cane as a young kid
yeah always wanted to be a hurricane you
know i went to
you know athletic park and obviously the
capeton so i'd be going down there you
know like watching jimmy gopper and like
crude and then
all those guys so i was like dead set on
being a hurricane and
during that lions during that lions
campaign um
actually mark hammett came in and sort
of told me that i was going to be in the
hurricanes by the training sport
oh yeah yeah so i was kind of i was just
like yes
like stoked my dream came true you know
like
i'm about to be in the hurricanes you
know albeit the one the training squad
but
i'm 18 years old at the time i don't i
don't really care i'm just like yes
like pumped up about it and then sort of
two weeks later jamie joe
um gave me a call and he was just like
oh hey mate i want you to come
down to dunedin um i was like oh there's
there's no point
i'm already you know why the training
squad you know because i just thought oh
he's only
well why am i going to be picked in a
full squad i've already just been given
a
by the training so i was like nah yeah
i'm i'm all good like sweethearts don't
worry about it and he's like
what do you mean and i was just like oh
i'm already in a wider training group
squad he's like now i want to give you a
full contract
wow and i was just like oh [ __ ] you know
like
and i was just like oh ah okay and then
you know classic jamie jones
well you got a you got a week to think
about it let me know um
and then just hangs up the phone you
know like i was just like oh wow
so i reckon i didn't know this but that
was the year i made the um hurricanes
wider scored so if you stayed i would
probably have never been a hurricane
that's buzzy
yeah so i got the wider squad when you
obviously went to the highlanders i
didn't know this until right
right then that's crazy oh it's mental
yeah so
so i went back to the hurricanes bro and
i was just like pleading with them like
oh i want to stay i want to stay
um you know give me a full contract but
at the time
they had cruds and i can't remember who
else maybe they had dan kirkpatrick as
well
yeah and body um yeah too
yeah so we were all like saying me so i
was just like pleading like and they
were
like just just riders and then
it was actually ma who convinced me to
go down eh oh yeah
yeah so he had obviously we had finished
the captain's run at the kaiten and
disloyal and all this kind of stuff you
know all these things you have in your
head because you're like
you know he's he's been at the hurricane
so long and
like it helped me out heaps that yeah
and then you pretty much told me that
like
you're not gonna learn you're not gonna
learn much holding tackle shields for
him
you know like the best way to learn is
to be out there and
actually be involved in the games and so
that was something that i like took on
board
and it was hard hard for me to like
leave at the time because the
highlanders
you know they weren't what they are now
like they were pretty sh they were
like [ __ ] like wooden spooners you know
like we went down there like we didn't
have like a proper gym or anything like
that
like the budget was terrible like
everything was terrible down there but
yeah he kind of just convinced me sort
of like to go down and just
chase my dream a different way and and
and that's kind of what i decided to do
is
just head down with a whole bunch of
young boys who jamie joe had sort of
picked because you know he wasn't gonna
get
the top all blacks to go down there and
he wasn't gonna get sort of
the guys who had been around super rugby
long enough
you know like sort of those those guys
who were really really solid
super players he wasn't going to
convince them so
he he sort of convinced sort of young
dudes who were
hungry and who had potential and then he
mixed that with
um sort of you know sort of the off cut
guys guys to
who other franchises sort of didn't
think were you know really good rugby
players you know
you're talking you know your jad
hoyastas and
you know the time aaron smith and and
guys like that so
yeah took the leap and and headed down
to the deep south
wow that's crazy shout out to martin and
jamie joe for
giving me a career and yourself
down in the highlanders it's always
seems to be like a real cool
environment down there you guys always
seem to have a real tight bond on and
off the
off the field um we've had a few guys on
already who
shared some pretty loose stories but
there seemed to be quite a cool cult
culture down there where you always seem
to get along
yeah it was really cool and that was
probably something that jamie joe had
really focused on was that when we went
down there there was probably only a
handful of guys who are actually from
the region
like we only had ben smith from the
region and
and maybe sort of one or two other guys
and so his his focus was really on
all of us becoming like a family and
becoming tight in that because all we
really had down there was each other
like none of us had like childhood
friends down there none of us
had gone to uni down there none of us
you know had
had had family or anything so the only
way we were gonna
um enjoy donating as if we got really
really close together
and i think that was the beauty of jbjo
was that he was able to
bring people together um different
cultures different backgrounds
um and what not and um yeah really
really make us sort of bond and then
your old man jamie joe gave you the
start first round how was that
yeah it wasn't it wasn't by choice i
don't think he would have picked me
until
round 20 if he had it if he had a choice
to be honest
but he was [ __ ] scraping the barrel
there uh
he had actually enticed lady to come
down from the crusaders
uh and so obviously slady was meant to
be the the number one guy
because i was just coming down as some
someone to learn
uh this lady actually broke his jaw in
the first
preseason game oh yeah he broke his jaw
yeah and so i ended up um being handed
the start and
funnily enough we were playing the
hurricanes
at westpac and i just remember so
you know we ran out first and i remember
standing there halfway without kickoff
and i was bouncing the ball up and down
you know like okay sweet this is gonna
be me
and then that was khalifa song came on
oh yeah yeah yeah and they came out like
an nfl team
like and i just remember standing
halfway thinking
what the [ __ ] am i doing here like this
is not the one bird like
bro their back line was pretty reaper at
nine they crewed in at ten
they admired twelve they had snakey at
13
they had jose on one wing jules on the
other and they had corey jane at full
back
stacked bro and i was just standing in
the middle like about to kick this ball
off like
oh my god i'm not i'm not qualified for
this
but we ended up we ended up winning uh
we ended up winning the game that day
bro which is crazy
um we won the game and i actually got um
i actually got first try score of that
game
and it's funny because one of my one of
my really good mates his old man
paid for his trip to las vegas because
he put
200 on me to score first try and i think
i was paying 35 on the nose
yeah i know he put he put it on a guy
playing 30
yeah 35 he put 200 straight up
first dry score oh that's good stuff
and you kept your starting spot after
that week yeah i kept there we played
the
chiefs played the chiefs um i kind of
hurt my shoulder
and then i wasn't able to go to south
africa after that we played the cheese
we won that game and then we went to
africa after that
but i i die on my shoulder i think i was
i think i was like actually on me and
miss him to be there but i was like a
skinny bony kid bro like
playing against these proper dudes so i
i definitely wasn't ready for
super my body wasn't ready for super
rugby at that time yeah
yeah physically i was just like nah i
wasn't i definitely wasn't up to it
and and then there was a moment early in
your career that most rugby players
dread especially
as a 10 as the sub before half time talk
me through that one
oh man i i love talking about the story
because
i actually look back and and i laugh
about it a lot
and like all my brothers and all my
really good mates we talked about it
heaps that's
that's actually a funny memory now but
at the time i just wanted to dig myself
the biggest hole
and jump in and just hope someone for a
bomb and then
it was honestly the worst thing ever i
don't think i've played um
such bag rugby in my whole entire career
to be to be honest
yeah well it was it was a really really
bad day at the office
we were playing the cheetahs and like
you know like the cheetahs aren't
traditionally that great and we're
playing them and
it just just didn't click for me like
nothing nothing went good
i think we went into the sheds at half
time maybe
28 7 down
or yeah yeah yeah something like that i
i'd given away like two intercepts like
two shots on goal pretty much in front
one i shanked and one i hit the post the
only good thing i did was set up kate
rookie in the corner and
i missed that goal kick as well sure
yeah i just
well it was it was just you know i think
it was just a bad bad day
and then jamie joe being who he
honestly was the worst feeling of my
life but
looking back now is something that i
look back on and i think oh
man i grew so much from that moment yeah
and you know
had i had so many laughs from it and you
know i always laughed about it because i
asked him
the year that he was leaving we were
sort of at the end of the year and i was
like bro
i asked him straight up so i was like
question i was
it still hurt me that he that he kind of
like suddenly yeah like three minutes
like come on bro
you could have just waited like three
minutes and then done the old
i see if they made a substitution at
half time yeah
[Laughter]
yeah and he just said no bro you needed
to be subbed
and uh that that's a lesson learned and
um exactly
if you've made it past the 37th minute
and again you know you're having a good
game
he just walked off drinking his heineken
or space or whatever he was drinking at
the time
so every time i kind of it's funny
because i look at the clock
um sort of near the end of the first
half and it's
past the 37th minute i just have a
little chuckle to myself
and just look at the clock
so you didn't want to come off a like
you were you were keen to keep playing
no i actually wanted to come off but i
was keen to at least go to half time
like save face like that but i knew that
like uh
i was like somebody saved me yeah like i
am drowning here
like get me out of this mix
but uh yeah i was hoping that he would
have just waited till half time and
done that thing like most people jamie
jones are
great lessons that's cracker and then
and another memory i have
yeah everyone remembers one of the most
razorless plays in super rugby history
i remember standing at fullback you turn
around kick it over your head
yeah so we've been analyzing you guys a
whole heap
and um brownies just reckon that if i
shake because we wanted to just do a
normal dink over top
but he said that corey jane you know
like corey jane's a mastermind
you know defensively and things like
that he's he's he's so
so clued up he said he'll put he'll put
that queue up straight away yeah he'll
be come back
but he said if you if you let the line
come to you and you turn around then
they
they probably don't know what you're
about to do yeah
and he was dead serious this is monday
morning he's like why don't you just
turn around and kick it over the top of
your
like kid like backwards and i was like
are you joking
he said nah i'm dead serious like i
reckon you can do it
and i was just like are you serious and
he's like no no yeah i'm dead seriously
i reckon we can do it
we'll have you turn around malakai will
switch and then another switch and then
you just like pop one over your shoulder
and i was upside oh sweet but he's the
kind of coach that
could make you feel like you could do
anything yeah but he he was just like
yeah sweet
i was like okay sweet but the whole week
bro it didn't come off once like
oh really kick it straight up in the air
one time it hit my
face but one time i missed the ball like
everyone was just thinking what the
[ __ ] why are we doing the stupid play
yeah um
and then we had that line out and we had
actually called call for a box kick
and then um why sake he just looked at
me was like oh do the kick i was like
oh [ __ ] i was like oh you're sweet and
then i just i just yelled canceled
tanagi
and then nug just looked at me like oh
[ __ ] he's gonna do it and he just knew
what to do he's just
like yeah sweet so he kind of i just
gave him the eyes and he like looked at
me he's like oh no way this fire's gonna
actually do it
and we ended up doing it i wish we had
scored oh
so close eh greatest one of the greatest
fights ever man it still hurts me that
we didn't score off that but
yeah it's a good little highlights feel
for me oh was it what one of the great
plays
yeah that was good stuff and the other
other thing obviously in your
highlanders career was the
2015 final and i guess the year you were
on absolute fire that whole season i
think you got
player of the year for the season and
capped off with the final
yeah it was just just the year where
i think sort of um into 2014 we were
able to make the playoffs for the first
time and we played the sharks
and um and we obviously lost in durban
but
that was kind of when tony brown came on
board and
and sort of jake um had made a lot of
changes and sort of
we had sort of learnt from our mistakes
but we we ended up making the
playoffs for the first time in 12 years
and after that game
i just just knew that there was more in
this team
and there was a couple of us who kind of
sat there after durban knowing that like
okay we lost but i reckon if we just
kind of like ride this out and like
stick together you know i think
is you know there's definitely juice to
be squeezed in this lemon you know what
i mean
there were some pretty special
characters in that team we had
um you know like alex amy and someone
who was really good for us was shane
christie and
he was someone that i really competed
with in the preseason
just like in the gym um and fitness and
stuff he
you know he's just like he's just like a
mad dog just so hungry so
just you know like it wasn't lit up you
know you know it was just infectious
it was just infectious i think we had
that kind of like
just if he was doing like extras like i
would jump in and do extras with no more
like
and that was kind of like what had
happened that year and
i think our confidence just grew and
grew and grew and um
you know me as a player my confidence
grew as well
just being around um brownie and sort of
building better relationships with like
maggie and
um bender and you know i had the had the
two feed gm boys sort of
catching my wayward cross kicks and
scoring cool tries
yeah it just you know it's it's a funny
old thing when you start to build my men
to me
yeah it just snowballs and the
the confidence that we had in each other
was was just
second to none and and i think it
probably helped that we were
um sort of like the landers and
and that like coming into the playoffs
we were
on a roll but no one really knew that we
were on a roll like the media weren't
blowing us up or anything like that
and we didn't sort of have the
the massive names on on paper we did
like we had you know
bender and and nagi and and muller they
were kind of like our big three and then
but we had like a really workman like
fought back
and so no one really gave us a chance to
be fair and
i think that was kind of like um
something that worked in our favors that
we kind of just flew under the radar
um a little bit and yeah we ended up
being the chiefs and then going to
sydney and then yeah we ended up beating
beating the cage which
you know i thought was probably one of
the best games to be a part of
you know and probably as a neutral was
probably a really good game to watch
yeah what what what stands out from that
game for you
obviously obviously marty's drop goal
um that stands out but i
i think probably when i knew it might be
our day was
when uh jules dropped the ball with the
line wide open oh yeah yeah yeah i think
it got a pass from brad
and that like i think we were on the
ropes right then and i think
when that when he just dropped the ball
you know like jules never drops the ball
it was just
i don't know what happened maybe he just
had a quick look at the the cornell was
wide open
and um that's when i kind of thought
oh man that the rugby gods looking down
on yesterday like
i think this could be could be our day
and then we end up you know like
mighty does the drop go and then uh we
get a scrum for a knock on and we just
kind of just
highlight those fashions just probably
like four minutes ago
they can go to the sideline [ __ ] go
and pick and go and then
kick it out you know so you came off
injured hey when banksy came on were you
confident did you think he could handle
the pressure coming off a
poor item cup final
nah me and me banksy always um we
always would have the awesome um chats
during the week and like
checking comps all the time so yeah i
always knew that
he was a pretty cool customer i think
the thing with banksy
was that like he actually has all the
skills
and stuff i just think he's got to
believe in himself yeah i actually think
he's a better kicker than me
um you know most of the time but i'll be
in his head saying
like how [ __ ] he is you know and and
like i'll be kind of like just chipping
away it was like
my confidence like sort of never wavered
but whereas
with with banksy i just think he just
needed a little bit of confidence
in himself because he's actually a like
a top quality footballer
um and the things that he can do and i
think some of the things he can do
is better than me it's just that there's
his confidence sometimes
i just think that leads him down but
yeah i knew when i came off i was like
like my cast was shot like i literally
couldn't walk yeah
and so i was like [ __ ] he's not
i mean he had been complaining all year
that he was getting splinters and then
now he's at this moment he's like [ __ ]
why are you coming off i'm like
get the [ __ ] on the field i can't walk
you through
you know oh my gosh that guy complains
all year he's not giving me the game
time comes to the biggest moment he's
like
oh [ __ ] stay on the field
oh well he came up trumps and he he he
came up with the goal
he came up trumps and he doesn't let
anyone forget about it yeah
does he work bloody he's a he's a top
quality bloke there crying we've got
such a special relationship
and you know he he was pretty good for
me at the landers and
probably just you know probably good for
him as well yeah for sure
at the end of that year you made the the
all black squad so
did you expect that call up the form was
that good that did you think it was
going to happen
nah especially in a world cup yeah i
don't i didn't think
i i thought i was no chance i just
thought oh you know
just they'll just do what they do and go
after
oh you know you had uh dc i think
cruds was actually injured at the time i
think maybe
um this lady and bodhisatt
i'm i'm well uh the equation yeah but
yeah i was
lucky enough to to um be involved and
then i got my shot in south africa which
was
pretty unbelievable to be fair yeah
tough test match to start
a way in south africa against the
massive south african four pack as a
team
not the easiest place to make your debut
but you obviously
absolutely killed it that day stayed on
played the 480
got past the 37 minute yeah yeah that
was that was actually one of my
things i'd written in my book i just put
the number 37
uh you know i just sort of wrote it down
and i just put 37
um next to sort of my game goals um
but yeah i i ended up starting that game
and i just thought
i i couldn't believe that i was starting
in south africa but yeah
it was actually um pretty crazy and
i just remember sort of putting the
black jersey on and then
like going to the mirror just before we
were about to walk out and like
splashing my face with water and then
looking up and i just like store myself
in the mirror and i was just like holy
[ __ ]
i felt like i would just like put this
like cloak of armor on and i was just
like oh man i'm ready
yeah but it's funny because i you know
like as a kid i dreamt about that moment
my whole life that when i walked down
the tunnel of ellis park i
actually felt like i had already been
there so many times just because as a
kid my mind would wander and i'd just be
like yeah like i'm gonna
play for the all blacks one day and you
know like it's going to happen so
so when it came to actually going down
there i was more excited by it
then daunted you know like that's cool i
was really excited by the occasion
rather than um you know pressured by it
yeah and i think that was because i
had these silly dreams all the way
through my childhood that i was going to
be an all black and
when it came to it it was almost like it
would
it had already happened it was like deja
vu and so
i just ended up going out there fit with
the mindset thinking like
if this was the one time you ever played
for the all blacks you might as well
just
play the game of your life yeah if you
never play again unless you know that
like you got to do it your way and so
that was my mindset going into it i was
just thinking
just throw the kitchen sink under and if
it's one test
then you bet that's all right that's
okay so you said it was 2015 when
um you were named so it was obviously
world cup year that later on that year
what was it like missing out on that did
you expect to make that side
like initially i i didn't expect to make
it
but after my south africa test i thought
man what dude young
dude at 24 years old gets the debut in
south africa
at 10 um and sort of like
sort of lead the team to to a win not
that i did it all by myself yeah i know
like that's a
pretty daunting sort of task to have
your first test in
in south africa at alice park
and i thought yeah i think i've given
everything that i can
and and i was kind of sort of
probably didn't help that maybe i had
heard you know i was kind of probably
listening to a bit of outside noise
saying you know like he's going to real
cut blah blah blah blah
but i knew in my heart that i'd given
everything and so
i i started to think that yeah actually
you know what i
i probably think that i deserve to go
here
and you know like i'm signed on um
to be in new zealand for a couple more
years so you know that
i'm not leaving or anything and and
whatnot
and yeah just it just didn't didn't work
out
uh for me and the selectors uh went a
different way which is
which is cool but just goes to show you
that you know like rugby is really one
man's opinion you know you can
you can you know like another coach
might have been like yeah he's coming to
the world cup yeah
you know we're sitting here talking
about how how
how was your world cup experience etc
but you know it really just comes down
to one man's opinion
and what not but honestly though it was
like at the time
it was like soul destroying oh true like
i remember just like
yeah i remember just it was sunday and i
remember
i remember getting the phone call and
like my dad was working
by his van and i remember just like
i remember that he was kind of like
pottering around sort of cleaning up a
few bits and pieces
and i remember just being like oh dad um
and i was just like already like
in my tears and i was like oh i didn't
make the world cup
and he was just like oh it's okay son
you know like
i think you know he was probably more
upset that would
than what he lit on but you know i just
felt at that moment
like telling my dad those words that i
missed out on the
world cup i almost felt like oh man i
i've sort of failed him and i
failed my like brothers and sisters and
i think all that kind of stuff was just
going through my head and i was just
like
i was like the straw day and like i look
back now and i just think oh man
like it's crazy because you look back
that at that moment you're like oh it's
that's not such a big deal yeah when
you're in that time
everything sort of heals things you know
and but when you're in the moment and
you're in that sort of all black bubble
and and you're
you're chasing you're chasing goals
you're chasing dreams
when you get that call it's like it's
like
soul-destroying but um yeah i had some
awesome people around me at that time
and
i think it was a sunday so we ended up
going out on a bit of a big
bender on me until my mates and
you know like they had worked the next
day but they're out drinking with me
it's a lot
freaking four in the morning um but
you know i was just like it's just one
of those things that you go through and
like
you know i look at people who have
missed out on um
squads or you know like going to the
olympics right now and you know yeah
people missing out on all sorts of
things
um with these big occasions coming up
and i just remember thinking
i just remember feeling like what it
felt like but being in this moment i am
now i just think like
oh man the sun still rises and there
will come another day where you kind of
like look back on that and you're just
like
oh man i'm so much better for that
experience yeah but you can't see it
when you're in that moment but no matter
what somebody tells you
you can't sort of get out of your that
hollowness
that you feel that real emptiness yeah
you know give it time and you you kind
of just look back at it and it's like
[ __ ] no one really cares man
you know i miss your initial like you're
like a proper big dog like
the big scheme of it no one really cares
you know like you're like richie or tc
like
your career
so how long did it take you to deal with
it because i know you've been a big
advocate for mental health and
you've done some real good work in that
area so any sort of tips or anything
about
how you would deal with that if you're
in the same spot again
yeah i think i'll deal with that a lot
better um
looking back now yeah i think i used
probably a lot of escapism
to get me through and i wish i had i
wish i had the tools
then that i do now and i wish i had gone
and
sort of seek help from someone external
whereas i kind of just
bottled it up and probably um bottled it
into
like i said escapism um buying [ __ ]
like going on benders all that kind of
stuff
whereas like you know like those are all
well and good and fun
yeah you get to that sunday and like
gravity's hit your head and you're just
like
oh man this is gravity and it's coming
down bro
and you know you're lying in your bed
you're like
oh man i mean you know you try and
you're trying because i think that would
have really helped me and i think
speaking to somebody
um who is external from your sort of
crew or someone who is completely away
from the environment that you're always
in so it's not like your mom your dad or
your
your missus or your best friends it's
you know someone who doesn't know
anything about rugby
or you know doesn't know and then i
think what they
what they end up doing is you actually
verbalize what's going on in your head
and you speak it out loud and you kind
of think
when you say some of the things that
upset you or whatever you're like
oh that's [ __ ] you're upset there
like you know what i mean yeah yeah and
that that was probably
some of the things that i went um
through overseas or whatever it was like
actually going to speak to somebody
about
um what you're feeling or what you're
sitting in isn't that scary
and actually it probably
speeds up the healing process a lot and
when you get to do that
you're not moving on quicker and then
your life just becomes so much easier
but i think as as men and especially as
male
rugby players opening up and talking
about our feelings isn't
um necessarily one of the first things
that we think about when
going through disappointment and just
think just gotta train harder
just gotta um you know sacrifice more
you just gotta you know do more gym
sessions or
you know not eat that snickers bar or
whatever
actually like if you if you go and talk
to somebody and
be able to sort of hear out what you're
what you're actually feeling inside then
that tends to be the
that tends to be what helped me that's
inspiring advice
good stuff in the mid podcast man that's
powerful
like that i don't know if it's powerful
it's probably just a bit of stupidity
i'm not trying to do it sooner you know
what i mean
yeah that's that's so true though it's
no one's first nature to go and speak
about especially in the rugby
environment but you can feel i can feel
a bit of a
shift at the moment it's becoming more
common guys are speaking out which is
encouraging others to do the same so i
think uh the game's going in the right
place
but um like you say it was it was never
easy especially
back then to go and try and talk to
someone yeah
yeah that'd be last time sort your head
out
but you found your way back into the all
black setup i think you played about 18
games
and then you decided to move over to the
uk
so what was the reason behind that move
yeah i just came at a
at a i was kind of just at a crossroads
i thought and
i was in an all black environment it was
very very solid and
um obviously you had bodhi there and i
just
i kind of just felt like um
no matter how good i was gonna be
playing i don't think i could unseat
c birdie at time you know like he was
just like the double
um you know back-to-back world play of
the year
and it would just it just seemed like
um the minutes i was getting off the
bench just wasn't really
um cutting it for me like i loved being
in the environment like
love being around the lads and and
and doing cool stuff and traveling the
world and whatnot but i just felt like i
was a bit part
um at times and
sort of heading into i think also
what sort of made me decide
um to leave in 2018 was
what i had gone through in 2015 and i
mean in the fact that
i could control what was going to happen
um between now
and say 2019 whereas if i may
like if i had decided to stay it still
wasn't
really fully in my hands yeah whether or
not i was going to go to a world cup
i could have done my knee and and been
out or
you know at the 11th hour the selectors
could have been like i actually were
gonna
go a different way um or you know or
maybe my phone might have dipped or
or things like that and it was it was
just like i didn't want to be
in a spot again where i had to go
through that pain i think
and like i was confident in myself that
i
would have given everything i didn't
want to give everything
and then get to a point where the
selectors
decided my fate yeah because you know
like i wasn't a protected species
like in that thing you know like the
guys who are always going to make it you
know like
your aaron smith your ben smith's your
brodies like those guys have nothing to
worry about
yeah whereas i was kind of just like one
of those guys who was like
replacement the squad but wasn't like
you know like really secure and
and that's just that was just like the
nature the nature of it and so
i didn't want to get to 2019 and and be
like
do everything that i think is possible
and then come to
come to the naming not get names because
of
like the choice of somebody else so i
wanted to take
my fate and my future into my own hands
and be like oh you know what i'm gonna
do something else and and try something
else and
and that's when i decided to go overseas
and you know like looking back now
i'm pretty pretty happy with that
decision and
and you know i have no regrets about
that decision at all and
it was just one of those things that i
just thought oh you know what i rather
decide my own future
rather than someone just decided for me
and yeah i might have gone to the world
cup but
at the end of the day you know who's to
say that i was gonna go
yeah and that's probably what it came
down to probably that fear of having to
pick myself up
again had i missed out that was probably
too
big of a mountain for me to climb i
reckon if i had
missed out it wasn't worth the risk in
my mind
to go through all that again so that's
that's kind of where it laid
that's that's cool that's cool to hear
and was it always wasps
was it always the wasps that you were
going to go to yeah there were a couple
of others but
you know to be frank wasps had the
biggest offense just blew the others out
of the water
it was a huge offer so we went
so so we decided to go there you know so
um yeah that's
um that's part of the reason why we went
there and
obviously we had different options but
yeah that was
that was and i knew sort of brad was
going there as well yeah
so i knew brad was going there so i was
kind of like happy that
you know i was going to know somebody
else and it was an english-speaking
country and whatnot and yeah that's
that's essentially what the decision
came down to and sort of like the why
what i was feeling at the time and and
all that kind of thing
very cool to hear and now at the end of
wasps you've signed with leon am i right
yeah going to leona france true talk me
through this one
because a lot of i know a lot of people
are expecting you to come home this
time around by the sounds but you know
you sort of miss new zealand rugby that
sort of thing but
um you've gone to france yeah to be
honest you know like it was
it was i was pretty close to coming back
to the hurricanes
i really you know we were pretty close
uh
but it just kind of just didn't
eventuate in the in the time frame that
i needed it to
and i think it sort of just yeah it was
just one of those things that we just
decided
because if we were coming back to new
zealand we were going to come back for
good
yeah and my mrs
said like she didn't want to come back
to new zealand and just spend a year and
then take off
again and try and pan or anything like
that or just be too hard like
why would you do that like if you're
away you might as well stay away
and then when you come home you actually
come home and that's that yeah whereas
i kind of was thinking oh yeah i
wouldn't mind coming back and
and playing in new zealand and then
taking off again but in her mind she was
just like well there's no real point
like what's the point of that you'll get
my hopes up and i'll
i'll get in a really good routine i'll
be happy back here and
and whatnot and then you're just gonna
ship us all the way oh we might as well
might as well stay away so yeah we um
we ended up uh deciding to go to france
then go to lyon and
i know the coach kenny lynn um i played
with him oh yes he's the head coach
oh sure well he's he's the backs coach
but i think him and the head coach
have like sort of like a dual role yeah
but he he speaks fluent french and
obviously i know him and he knows me so
i think that's
that's uh a real bonus of sort of
heading to lyon and
so yeah that's that's where we're
heading now we're getting to be on
another adventure and that's just a
one-year deal this time
no that's a that's a that's a two plus
one oh is it
she's you've gone again you're in it
yeah well i'm 30 now bro so yeah i know
i've probably only got you know like
this one and
you know if i can strap my knees
hard enough and get the tape around them
um maybe they'll hold me up for one more
after that you know
yeah and then i'll come home but
yeah that's um that's where we're at
with that and
yeah look at look really excited for it
to be fair
i think the learnings and and the things
i experienced in the uk would definitely
help
us sort of not only on the field but off
the field yeah and that's one thing a
lot of people don't realize when they
see players
making these decisions is your family
your partner
and your kids i mean moving them to
other countries is a big deal and having
to settle the whole family in at a new
place so
like you say it makes a lot of sense to
stay over there until you come back and
settle
and i'm guessing your kids will be about
school age that time so
they don't have to move schools and
things like that there's all these
little things in the background that
no one sees about a rugby player's
decision they just see
our lemurs off to leave yes yeah so like
there's a lot of factors that come into
it so
i mean you know when you when you're
moving overseas you're obviously giving
up stuff as well you know you're giving
up
the chance to be around your own family
you know i've got brothers and sisters
and so my brother's got kids as well and
just
missing that as well and my missus um
her brothers have kids as well and so we
do miss that and
you can't have everything in life you
know so we decided to
sort of just stay on this overseas
journey and
and try and really um embrace it all and
experience it all because we know when
we come back to museum we're coming back
and that's that and
i'll never be going all the way over the
other side of the world i think it was
too [ __ ] fine
so would you look to come back at the
end of that and have one more stint in
new zealand one more
swan song with maybe the canes and lions
or stags i know a lot of questions are
coming about you and returning to the
stags you obviously
had a big impact down there with the
boys
yeah i i wouldn't have a clue i think
you know by the time i finish this
contract i think i'll be 32
yeah i'll be 32 so you know maybe i
might do one more
year overseas i really love to get to
japan you know i really love to get
there as well and experience life they
are
and they'll be bloody cool to be able to
stay
you know played in new zealand and uk
and france and japan but yeah and we'll
just
just gotta keep the body healthy and and
play as well as i can and then
that'll let me decide where i can go
eventually
it's in life after footy plans not too
sure yet
i think that's what i've got to sort of
get locked down now over the next five
years
and and sort of work out what i want to
do i wasn't
i wasn't too sure about coaching i
thought i might want to get it
get away from rugby but now i'm kind of
like oh actually i wouldn't mind
having a good crack at coaching and um
just seeing
seeing where that could take me and your
podcast you i haven't seen your podcast
up in running recently what's happened
there that was that was hissing while it
was going
yeah boy boys have been on furlough man
[Laughter]
no government funding
at the moment now we're just being slack
yeah honestly we're just being slack and
useless
on it uh to be fair but yeah it is it is
quite cool
uh podcasting isn't it um as you would
know you get to kind of talk to some
pretty cool people
yeah and hear their stories and you know
you get to really
um understand somebody or like
see why they do stuff or you know some
of the experiences they have and
um it is really cool but yeah we're just
being slack bro
is it something you'd look to push later
on or see how you go
yeah i think so i think so i think um
yeah we just got to sit down and have a
proper think about what what you want to
do
um probably a bit like yourself it's
just like just getting the reps in
constantly and just
you know eventually just building up
momentum trying to be consistent hey
that's the hardest thing i mean
consistent if you can get out regular
consistent episodes then
people seem to listen but as soon as you
drop off for like a week it's like oh
where have they
gone yeah yeah yeah that's about like us
i still get this just like yo where's
the pokemon
yeah yeah and then it's the same guy who
asked me again
sorry
but as always we've gone to instagram
for some questions we do have a lot of
questions but i'll race through some
heaps of these questions were would you
come back to the canes would you come
back to the stags
everyone wants you to return to the
mighty canes
uh first question from marty banks
what did he give brownie to get a
hundred percent game time and zero
training minutes
oh my gosh oh that guy's funny eh
he to be fair we did do a lot of my reps
to be honest yeah but
it paid off in the end a in the final
yeah it paid off you basically top
trainer though
probably the most meters during the week
but come come game days only [ __ ]
run on the pitch after the game you know
doing the extra fitness with the trainer
like oh good stuff okay
who wins it in a run it straight between
you and your brother tupa
oh older brother always thinks he can
but
he'll definitely steamroll me over
i i probably i'd probably like lay my
life on the line not to get bold over
as the older brother
yeah yeah just you just have to throw it
at you and see what happens
but is he playing for the cook islands
in a few weeks against the mighty marco
i saw his name on the squad
yeah yes he reckons he's captain he goes
oh man
i'm i'm just like my cousin sonny bill
williams jewel international
the boys are gonna have to watch out for
him he thinks yeah i'm like
oh that's classic okay richard buckman
or marty banks
they're good for different reasons but
if i'm in from a dark
alley it's like the 80th minute sorry
banksy
yeah you're out mate the barracuda's
coming in and he's making the tackles
for me bro
as soon as she said the dark alley i
knew where that one was going
okay um would you ever try and play for
samoa
yeah to be fair i actually um
try to do the switch like malachi yeah
obviously malachi is doing that um he
played in monaco i actually wanted to be
a part of that
uh with the seven set up and it just
didn't work out because
my miq voucher was for the 16th of june
and we couldn't get it moved so that me
and my whole family could come back
because we had already booked our fights
and stuff oh that's right you know
we couldn't book it miq voucher for all
of us
they could they could book one for for
just me
but that was flying from the uk
to new zealand and then doing two weeks
quarantine and that's just a step too
fast yeah this is you know like
that's three kids three number right
[Laughter]
yeah i couldn't do that to her yeah like
i really wanted to
um but it was just i had to put um
sort of my family first in that
situation it's just unfortunate that
that was the way that it had happened
and i couldn't get i couldn't get back
home into the country
but it's something you're looking to do
going forward yeah i would have
definitely been keen to do it that's
cool keen to try and
and and help out some more um and
you know and play for them
you know i would have been king for sure
next world cup
hey how good would that be okay next one
how much weight
and skinnies did you put on in your
first south africa tour
oh this is the tits bro
this is the that's this question this is
honestly
that's this question so my favorite
self-interest i think i missed the first
four
tours injuries yeah just injuries just
um yeah just all injuries and so the
first one i made i was like
making up for it right those milkshakes
say
holy they are unbelievable
and uh what is it those passion fruit
lemonades
you know and the room service you know
the room server because everything's so
cheap there you know yeah
they're so weak yeah and even when
you're spending new zealand dollars
you're like
i think you're a millennial so yeah i
think
i think i actually put on like five kilo
and
i went up like 25 million
[Music]
in two weeks
honestly i think i was having like i
think i averaged like
2.2 milkshakes a day or something like
that i worked it out
all right i must have been having a
milkshake for breakfast
game day honestly
[ __ ] idiot but yeah i i
i lost the gherkin when i went over
there i was just
like i can't believe i'm here i've
waited so long for this you know
oh that's good stuff okay last question
what happened between kate porky and
james haskell
oh man anyone who knows kate like that
guy's
like that guy can proper scrapper
shortest fuse
oh my shortest views [ __ ] you know but
holy that guy can't fight man so yeah
essentially what happened i i cracked
the egg on haskell's head
and everyone starts cracking up laughing
and like losing the plot
at him having a he cracked on his head i
run back to the wall and
like where i was drinking i was drinking
with adam thompson
and haskell ends up like flying through
the fire
that we've made in this house like we've
made this bonfire and because everyone's
kind of like
just over haskell at the time you know
he can just talk and talk and talk and
talk
you know like doesn't shut up like funny
the funniest guy
this time everyone's just had enough you
know yeah and so they
started to chuck all his like clothes in
there his food
like his [ __ ] brown rice getting
chucked in the fire he's he's not having
it you know
um so he comes back
flies through the fire right and i'm not
talking like a little fire it's like a
[ __ ] roaring blaze right now yeah
like it's like proper like
in the ear kind of thing and he like
runs through it and i'm just like
standing there
and he just like bang just drops me like
a cold true
i just wake up on yeah like i just wake
up on the ground
like [ __ ] my jaw sore man and out of
like
out of the corner of my eye but kate's
cade's seen it
and he just sprints across like
from out of nowhere and he just starts
full online
like him and haskell were like going
into it bro
and like must like try to grab and just
like just kind of like subdue him and
he's like rip this top in case just like
rip this top
and he's just like that's my best friend
[Laughter]
he's like
i don't know he's got like the
incredible hulk inside
yeah he just like he just like full on
lost today
had to go and get stitches from a e oh
really nice
wow yeah because because kate got him so
good but
yeah it's it was a it was good laughs
mate kate has your back
geez yeah yeah that guy's the best
and what a career mate what a what a
journey that you've been through it's
been
it's been awesome actually to just catch
up and go through your
journey like that um lots of things that
i i didn't know
and picked up through that heaps of
heaps of cool advice mate really
appreciate you giving up your time
to come on the waterlab podcast really
appreciate it mate
nah no ways jimmy thanks bro thanks for
having me on appreciate what you do and
like i said i've learned some pretty
cool things off
some of the other people have been on
your show and i think what you're doing
is
is pretty cool so like you said before
bro just
consistency keep banging them out
thanks for having me on brian i really
appreciate uh coming on and being able
to share with you today and
glad to know i was able to sort of play
a small part in your career oh a huge
part
wait i'll still be battling with tasman
appreciate it thanks mate
[Music]
what